in this video we're going to talk about
regression lines but it's not going to
be the first time we're talking about
regression lines and so if the idea of
our aggression is foreign to you I
encourage you to watch the introductory
videos on it here we're gonna think
about how we can make inferences from a
regression line and so the idea of
statistical inference is new to you or
hypothesis testing once again watch
those videos as well but let's say we
think there's a positive association
between shoe size and height and so what
we might want to do is we could here on
the horizontal axis that is shoe size
our sizes could go size 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 and it could keep going up
from there and then on this height or on
this axis our y-axis this would be
height so one foot two feet three feet
four feet five feet six feet seven feet
and then you could to see if there's an
association you might take a sample say
you take a random sample of 20 people
from the population and in future videos
we'll talk about the conditions
necessary for making appropriate
inferences let's say those 20 people are
these 20 data points so there's a young
child and maybe there's a grown adult
with bigger feet and who's taller and
then 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 and so you have these 20
data points and then what you're likely
to do is input them into a computer you
could do it by hand but we have
computers now to do that for us usually
and the computer could try to fit a
regression line and there's many
techniques for doing it but one typical
technique is to try to overall minimize
the squared distance between these
points and that line and this regression
line will have an equation as any line
would have and we tend to show that as
saying Y hat this hat tells us that this
is a regression line is equal to the y
intercept a plus the slope times our X
variable so this right over here would
be a now to be clear if you took another
sample you might get different results
here inside fact let's call this y sub
one for our first sample a sub one B sub
one and this is a sub one if you were to
take another sample of twenty folks so
let's do that maybe you get one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 and then
you tried to fit a line to that that
line might look something like this
it might have a slightly different
y-intercept and a slightly different
slope so we could call that for the
second sample y sub 2 or Y hat sub 2 is
equal to a sub 2 plus B sub 2 times X
and so every time you take a sample you
are likely to get different results for
these values which are essentially
statistics remember statistics are
things that we can get from samples and
we're trying to estimate true population
parameters well what would be the true
population parameters we're trying to
estimate well imagine a world imagine a
world here that you are able to find out
the true linear relationship or maybe
there is some true linear relationship
between shoe size and height you could
get it if theoretically you could
measure every human being on the planet
and depending what you define as a
population it could be all living people
or all people will ever live this isn't
practical but let's just say that you
actually could and you you would have
billions of data points here for the
true population and then if you were to
fit a regression line to that you could
view this as the true population
regression line and so that would be Y
hat is equal to and to make it clear
that here the y-intercept in the slope
this would be the true population
parameters instead of saying a we say
alpha and instead of saying B we say
beta times X but it's very hard to come
up exactly with what alpha and beta are
and so that's why we estimate it with
A's and B's based on a sample now what's
interesting with this in mind is we can
start to make inferences based on our
sample so we know that that for example
B sub 2 is unlikely to be exactly beta
but how
confident can we be that there is at
least a positive linear relationship or
a nonzero linear relationship or can we
create a confidence interval around this
statistic in order to have a good sense
of where the true parameter might
actually be and the simple answer is yes
and to do so we'll use the same exact
ideas that we did when we made
inferences based on proportions or based
on means the way that you can make an
inference for example for your true
population slope of your regression line
say okay I took a sample I got this
slope right over here so I'll just call
that b2 and then I could create a
confidence interval around that and so
that confidence interval is going to be
based on some critical value x ideally
the standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of your sample statistic in
this case it would be the sample
regression line slope but because we
don't know exactly what this is we can't
figure out precisely what this is going
to be from a sample we are going to
estimate it with what's known as the
standard error of the statistic and
we'll go into more depth in this in
future videos and since we're estimating
here we're going to use a critical T
value here which we have studied before
and so based on your confidence level
you want to have let's say it's 95%
based on the degrees of freedom which
we'll see we'll come out of how many
data points we have we can figure this
out and from our sample we can figure
this out and we can figure this out and
then we would have constructed a
confidence interval we'll also see that
you could do hypothesis testing here you
could say hey let's set up a null
hypothesis and the null hypothesis is
going to be that there's no non zero
really linear relationship or that
there's or that the true population
slope of the regression line or slope of
the population regression line is equal
to 0 and that the alternative hypothesis
is that the true relationship could
either be greater than 0 it's a positive
linear relationship or that it's just
non zero and then what you could do is
assuming this you could see what's the
probability of getting a statistic that
is at least this extreme or more extreme
and if that's below some threshold you
might reject the null
potus's which would suggest the
alternative so this and this are things
that we have done before where you're
creating a confidence interval around a
statistic or you're doing hypothesis
testing making assumptions about a true
parameter the only difference here is
that the parameter that we're trying to
estimate are going to be the parameters
for a theoretical population or gresham
line and we're going to do that using
sample statistics for a sample
regression line